nous vous remercions d'avoir accepté
cette invitation et 17 échange avec les
membres de de la commission vous êtes un
des premiers à avoir si ce n'est
peut-être le premier d'ailleurs mais à
avoir soulevé la la question du respect
de la laïcité dans les établissements
scolaires et et des tensions générées
par des manifestations d'appartenance
religieuse je rappelle mais les membres
de la commission ont longtemps à
l'esprit que votre premier travail au
nom de l'inspection générale du reste
date de 2004 un rapport que vous aviez
remis à l'époque à votre tutelle que en
2020 plus récemment vous avez écrit un
ouvrage intitulé comment on a laissé
l'islamisme pénétrer à l'école donc
seize années plus tard vous avez là
aussi publiquement pris la parole pour
dénoncer un certain nombre de phénomènes
constatés dans les écoles évidemment ce
sera pour nous important de savoir
comment et évoluer d'après vous la
situation entre 2004 et et et 2020 et
est-ce que vous avez bien sûr des
recommandations à faire je sais que vous
insistez beaucoup sur les questions la
formation des enseignants et des
personnels de l'éducation nationale
c'est un sujet qui me préoccupe aussi
jeu je ne citerai que le sénateur
grosperrin qui est derrière son écran et
qui dans son rapport budgétaire de cette
année avait bien souligné l'importance
d' insister sur la formation des
enseignants à la laïcité
il ya quelques semaines le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer vous a confié une mission sur
ce thème très important que vous nous
préciser le périmètre et les bouches de
quelques pistes de réflexion bien
entendu ce
cette audition ce matin se déroule comme
je le rappelais dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi
est ce que pour vous c'est une omission
ou et ce n'est pas dans un dispositif
législatif sur cet aspect là je dirais
bien sûr la parole ou trois rapporteurs
à l'issue de votre propos préliminaires
et puis après je ne doute pas que chacun
des sénateurs
les représentants des groupes ou
individuellement auront des questions à
vous poser donc sans plus tarder je vous
donne la parole et messieurs mesdames
dessinateur de m'avoir invité je suis
honoré de cette invitation et je vais
essayer en quelques minutes de d'engager
une discussion un échange avec vous en
faisant l'histoire le panorama très
rapide très synthétique de la manière
dont l'école en est arrivé un point qui
est j'en prends conscience tous les
jours dans ma mission de plus en plus
inquiétant j'avoue que par rapport à la
période où j'ai écrit mon livre 2017
2019 2018-2020 plutôt les choses ont
encore empiré et chaque jour de
nouvelles indications de nouvelles
enquêtes
de nouveaux travaux montrent que les
choses s'aggravent dans l'école dans la
société sans doute mais particulièrement
dans l'école parce que un des points sur
lequel je voudrais insister c'est
aujourd'hui que je pense nous devons
qu'on perde une bataille
la laïcité a perdu une bataille
vis-à-vis de la jeunesse musulmane qui
est qui montre aujourd'hui qu'elle est
de plus en plus est très largement
pénétré par l'idéologie islamiste alors
quelques repères chronologiques sur 7
sur le comment on en est arrivé là
je vous rappelle quelques points qui
sont aussi des points 2-2 mon histoire
personnelle en tant qu'inspecteur
général j'ai été nommé en 1990 mais j'ai
toujours travaillé dans l'éducation
nationale et en particulier dans
certains cabinets ministériels une
époque où l administration centrale et
la sphère de creil à faire des foulards
du collégienne c'est le premier signe
qu'on ne sait pas interpréter vraiment
de l'arrivée d'un certain nombre de
prédicateur dans les quartiers qui
endoctrinent des jeunes en particulier
les jeunes filles pour affirmer
publiquement la présence dans la
communauté musulmane d'une idéologie à
laquelle il invite l'ensemble des
musulmans à se soumettre
li de l'islamiste des prédicateurs venus
du maghreb en l'occurrence ici des
marocains mais ensuite qui sait se
mouvant va s'accélérer au milieu des
années 90 évidemment avec la fin de la
guerre de la guerre civile en algérie
l'aministie dont les terroristes vont
bénéficier et leur arrivée massive dans
les cartes il en france je vous renvoie
par exemple aux livres deboosère de
bouchera azzouz l'autobiographie où elle
raconte très précisément comment ce
qu'elle appelle ce que les habitants de
ces quartiers à l'époque appelle les
blédard arrive et arrive à convaincre
petit à petit les jeunes filles
notamment pas seulement les jeunes à se
convertir à cette idéologie
un peu plus tard c'est perçu mon
expérience personnelle
c'est le début des années 1990 et
à propos enfin à l'occasion de la
première guerre du golfe
ce qu'un certain nombre de chefs
d'établissement me signale dans
l'académie de lyon dont je suis
responsable
à savoir ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la
radicalisation sur des jeunes des élèves
collégiens lycéens qui n'ont plus peur
de manifester leur opinion radicale qui
taguent les murs qui crient des slogans
et ils prennent le parti de saddam
hussein à l'époque contre la collecte la
coalition arabe au occidental et puis
ensuite on a en 2002 pendant 1996 en
tant qu'inspecteur général je suis
confronté à ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
le nouvel antisémitisme
c'est à dire un principal de collège de
lyon qui me dit que ces derniers et les
juifs on est obligé de quitter le
collège 7 la semaine où jules visite et
je m'aperçois de ce phénomène
donc qui n'est pas propre à ce collège à
savoir 1
les violences verbales et physiques dont
sont victimes dont beaucoup
d'établissements scolaires les ailes
juifs
le départ de ses élèves vers
l'enseignement catholique très peuvent l
enseignement juifs qui est pas capable
de 2,2 de les accueillir
faute de place et verdi établissements
publics de centre-ville protéger le
mérite à 6 et celle des services
académiques de l'éducation nationale
quiero case de la manière la plus
discrète possible ses élèves sans que
jamais cette affaire ce scandale soit
mis sur la place publique 2002
publication les territoires perdus de la
république
et là je prends conscience en lisant ce
livre cette fois ci d'être d'attac qui
sont qui visent des contenus
d'enseignement donc autre manifestation
de l'islamisme des ouvrages de
philosophie de l'être la théorie de
l'évolution en histoire-géographie toute
une série de questions
et puis la faire à ce moment là la
question arrive sur la place publique
vous connaissez la commission stasi la
décision du président chirac le vote de
la loi et en même temps vous saviez
l'archos qui est à l'époque ministre de
l'enseignement scolaire nous confie
instructions générales le soin d'aller
enquêter dans les établissements
scolaires sur les signes manifestations
d'appartenance religieuse c'est moi qui
suis à l'initiative de cette de cette
demande qui est acceptée par le ministre
et mon intuition c'est que la question
du voile qui polarise l'attention
publique mais que l'arbre qui cache la
forêt
et qu'en réalité les atteintes à la
laïcité sont bien plus vastes bien plus
nombreuses et bien plus diverses et
c'est ce qui établit notre rapport qui
est enterré vous le savez par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
changement de gouvernement oblige de
l'époque c'est-à-dire françois fillon et
puis ensuite il reste enterré jusqu'en
2015 jusqu'aux attentats de janvier où
un autre homme politique ça voir manuel
valls premier ministre à l'époque les
xoom en quelque sorte et dit
publiquement dans une conférence de
presse dans tout était déjà là en fait
ce que je je je montre quelques années
plus tard c'est à dire dans mon livre
plus que je commence en 2018
c'est que les choses ont bien empirer
dans beaucoup de domaines pendant c'est
15 ans ont tout perdre 11 ans jusqu'en
2015 où on n'a pas fait grand chose on
n'a ni la poussière sous le tapis et on
a laissé un mot ou suivant successeur le
soin de régler des problèmes qui sont
des problèmes difficiles certes mais s'y
engage la france et qui engage deux
lanternes
donc voilà rapidement brossé l'évolution
que j'ai vécu de la pénétration de
l'islamisme dans l'école et veut la
manière dont on y reviendra sans doute
les un certain nombre de responsables
politiques ou institutionnels et plus
généralement l'ensemble des acteurs n'a
pas pris ce propre ce problème à bras le
corps la laisser se développer pour
arriver une situation aujourd'hui qui
est difficilement maîtrisable je pense
que vos questions vont porter en
particulier là dessus quelques
illustrations de l'état des lieux
aujourd'hui à partir de 2015
las de cette prise de conscience en tout
cas prise de conscience plus large est
en tout cas cette cet aveu du monde
politique qu'il irait effectivement un
problème qui n'avaient pas été traitées
se développe beaucoup de recherches
financées d'ailleurs par des fonds
publics et toute une série d'études qui
sont commandités par des acteurs privés
associatifs 8 et national d'action
laïque le
la fondation l'institut montaigne etc et
dont le dernier qui est puis qui a été
publié il ya une semaine
commandité par la licra et l'ifop donne
les indications peut-être les plus
inquiétantes 2016 le premier le premier
première étude quantitative objective et
celle de l'institut montaigne de hakim
el karoui
un quart des musulmans de france dit il
adopte des valeurs contraires à celles
de la république
mais qu'on n'a pas dit à l'époque les
plus jeunes 50% et on voit pour la
première fois à paraître ce que
j'appelle la rupture générationnelle
entre les musulmans et les 15 24 ans
simplement la tranche la plus basse
interrogé dans ses enquêtes qui toujours
voisine un rapport de 1 à 2 dès qu'on
essaye de caractériser l'influencé
islamiste sur ces catégories de
population un sondage pour le comité
national d'action laïque de l'ifop en
2018 donne pour la première fois des
indications chiffrées deux sur d'un
échantillon représente est représentatif
des enseignants français sur ce qui se
passe dans leur classe et ses chiffres
aujourd'hui je les donne pas puisque un
autre sondage beaucoup plus récents
donnent des chiffres beaucoup plus
inquiétant mais c'est pour la première
fois on voit évaluer quantitativement ce
que nous disions intuitivement
subjectivement dans notre rapport de
2004 c'est que la principale manière
dont les enseignants réagissent à cette
pénétration de l'islamisme c'est
l'autocensure et on voit apparaître un
chiffre
bon sur l'autocensure 37 % des
enseignants français de kars est déjà
auto sens yonne on verra que aujourd'hui
dans le dernier rapport
après laffaire pâtit c'est 50%
une enquête qui est peu connue de
sébastien roché cnrs grenoble le rapport
à la loi de l'adolescence une enquête
intéressante parce qu'elle est
européenne et c'est le volet france là
mais que cette enquête ne portent pas
spécifiquement sur la religion sur la
laïcité il y a à 17 volet qui porte sur
7 sur 7 thématiques et là on a demandé
aux collégiens 11 mille collégiens
interrogés
on leur a demandé leur religion déclaré
on peut classer selon la religion et on
voit que sur tous les items il y à une
rupture la retrouver dans d'autres
enquêtes entre les jeunes collégiens
musulmans les jeunes collégiens non
musulmans qu'ils soient athées
agnostiques ou catholiques les autres
religions présentes sont trop peu
significative trois exemples la femme
est fait avant tout pour faire des
enfants et les élever 16% sans religion
sont d'accord avec çà 30% les
catholiques 41%
le musulman une loi heurte les principes
religieux que fais tu je suis mes
principes religieux catholiques 34 %
musulman 68% et surtout cette cette
réponse qui mérite d'être méditée les
espèces vivantes sont le résultat de
l'évolution mérite m deuxième idée
l'autre réponse possible non du a créé
les espèces vivantes telles qu'elles
sont jolies et d'ailleurs le
questionnaire était très précis ont
donné l'exemple du chat du cheval
hectares
pour ce faire vous bien se faire
comprendre sans religion 66% pensent que
le professeur dit vrai en quelque sorte
catholique 30 % musulman 6% en une une
marque de l' influence obscurantistes
cette fois-ci de l'idéologie islamiste
sur les jeunes musulmans
alors on a ensuite le sondage de 2020
qui est le sondage qui avait été
commandité par charlie et le comité
laïcité république
là je tiens je vous donne de résultats
significatifs en général fait de vous
passez vos convictions religieuses avant
les valeurs de la république
chez les musulmans 40 % chez les moins
de 25 ans musulman 74%
on retrouve cette rupture
générationnelle et surtout cette
question qui est une question qui est
posée par l'ifop manière traditionnelle
sur le plan politique l'islam est
incompatible avec les valeurs de la
société française traditionnellement
plus on est à droite plus au ray pour
ouvrir cette question l'extrême droite
les les français qui disent voter à
l'extrême droite dans les plus nombreux
à approuver cette assertion est là on a
posé la question aux musulmans et aux
jeunes plus jeunes 15 24 ans 29 % des
musulmans sont d'accord avec la et 45%
des plus jeunes donc aujourd'hui
bon les choses évoluent en d'ailleurs
très vite on a sans doute plus de la
moitié des jeunes musulmans qui pensent
que leur région est incompatible avec la
vie dans la société dans laquelle ils
sont mais quelques quelques indications
sur ce que déclarent les enseignants sur
ce qu'ils vivent dans leur classe avec
le sondage pour la fondation jean jaurès
de janvier dernier
bon je vous passe beaucoup de choses la
vie scolaire l'enseignement
avez vous déjà rencontré des
contestations de votre enseignement au
nom de la religion
on a bon une majorité qui répondent oui
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est de
classe et par discipline enseignée et on
a arrive en tête l'éducation physique et
sportive avec près de 30% des
professeurs qui ont observé des
contestations de leur enseignement ce
qui ne m'étonne pas ensuite on à
l'histoire géographie les sciences de la
vie et de la terre les lettres les arts
la musique etc
aucune discipline n'était pas renier
mais dans des proportions différentes
enfin la fameuse question sur l'auto
censure afin d'éviter de possibles
incidents
vous est il déjà arrivé de vous auto
censure et 45 49 % un enseignant sur
deux déclare aujourd'hui s'être auto
censurés par rapport au sondage de 2018
c'est 13 points de plus et là c'est ce
que les analystes appellent l'effet
pâtit c'est à dire l'assassinât de
samuel patty a provoqué vraiment un
électrochoc dans la communauté
enseignante et maintenant la peur la
crainte s'est installée plus largement
qu'elle ne l'était déjà
et donc c'est pas parce qu'on a
rencontré des contestations c'est qu'on
a peur de possibles incidents que l'on
décide de ne pas traiter tel point du
programme obligatoire
ensuite on a toute une série de
questions sur le séparatisme qui donne
corps à cette idée de séparatisme à
travers les réponses des des enseignants
qui sont extrêmement détaillées sur
toute une série de sujets je ne je ne
vous infligerait pas cela mais ce
sondage est consultable sur internet
enfin on a le dernier sondage qui a été
publiée la semaine dernière de l'ifop
toujours pour la licra sur les sondages
auprès d'un échantillon représentatif
des lycéens français avec analyse de
leurs déclarations de religion et on a
aujourd'hui bon une
je dirais un double phénomène qui
apparaît dans ce sondage les deux ces
deux volets de ce phénomène et sont
inquiétants d'abord les auprès des
jeunes musulmans lycéen musulman pardon
on a 80 cents les questions 80 à 90% de
deux jeunes lycéens musulmans qui
exprime une conception punitive de la
laïcité voient la laïcité c'est quelque
chose qui est fait pour qui est anti
musulmans qui est fait pour nous
contraindre qui s'adressent à nous
spécifiquement et qui est une marque
donc j'aime pas du tout les termes mais
il est pratique et d'islamophobie
c'est à dire de racisme anti musulman
et ce qui est encore plus inquiétant
peut-être c'est une partie des autres
lycéens non musulmans les suivent dans
cette appréciation de fait que sur
l'ensemble des lits sien on en est à peu
près à 55 50 % 50 % évidemment si on
inclut les musulmans dans l'échantillon
et c'est à peu près 14 % de
l'échantillon
ils font basculer l'équilibré du côté de
la conception punitive de la laïcité et
la demande de lever toutes les
contraintes liées à la religion dans les
établissements scolaires puisqu'une
majorité s'exprime même pour que les
fonctionnaires les enseignants puissent
manifester leur religion dans leur
l'exercice professionnel et pas
seulement les enseignants l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires
comment en est on arrivé là mais je
pense que c'est peut-être l'objet de la
discussion qui va suivre mais dans mon
livre j'ai mais un certain nombre je
fais un certain god analyse qui touche
d'abord le monde politique
et puis ensuite l'institution éducative
l'éducation nationale très rapidement je
pense qu'il ya trois grands
trois grands facteurs qui ont qui ont
contribué à ce déni à ce bond à cet
abandon de cette question ce report du
traitement de cette question
bon il ya d'abord la naïveté qui aboutit
à la cécité ou je me suis heurté sans
arrêt à cela au moment où j'ai soumis
mon rapport toute une série de gens au
seul ministère de l'éducation nationale
qui cotisent et comment c'est pas vrai
ce que vous dites n'est pas vrai moi
j'ai pas vu ça donc c'est pas vrai des
anciens responsables académiques
directeur d'anciens acteurs des
inspecteurs d'académie mon département
dans mon académie c'est pas vrai ça
n'existe pas on nous avions nous avions
écrit dans notre rapport que précisément
partout nous étions allés les
responsables des pauvres on de ce qui se
passait je fais les descendre dans les
classes pour que des gens glisse voit ce
qui se passe mais le chef
d'établissement commença à dire non je
suis moi y rien pouvait les voir mes
profs et se passe rien et lorsqu'on
allait voir l'inspecteur dès qu'il me
voit le recteur nombreux départements
dont mon académie vous trouverez rien et
on a toujours trouvé quelque chose donc
le déni une sorte de naïveté
et puis pour ceux qui j'ai compris ce
qui se passait mais qui avait pas
courage de le traiter
je pense la lâcheté l'accord vise et
puis enfin chez un certain nombre de
responsables à tous niveaux
la complaisance idéologique c'est à dire
l'adhésion vous fait qu' il y avait
quelque chose qui était normale dans
cette situation les musulmans étant des
victimes
bon il se défend des communes qu'ils
pouvaient et au fond l'idéologie
islamiste et ses skis simon teller leurs
ardeurs révolutionnaires qu'il fallait
encourager
il y avait tout un certain nombre de
terrains
où il était possible de collaborer la
lutte contre l'impérialisme contrôle
sionisme et c'est ça se rend compte
quand même beaucoup
aujourd'hui encore peut-être surtout
dans les salles des profs
à l'université on aura peut-être
l'occasion de parler de l'université y
compris à l'université je lui dis dans
les centres de formation des enseignants
aujourd'hui la droite comme la gauche au
pouvoir pendant cette période entre 2004
et et 2015 pour des raisons différentes
que je ne développera pas trop ici tout
se développe dans mon livre on laissait
faire
7 cette évolution ne l'ont pas traité à
l'intérieur de l'institution
et bien ce dont on s'aperçoit assez pour
être très court du côté des professeurs
je commencerais par eux un grand
désarroi face à cette question le
sentiment de ne pas être soutenus du
tout par la hiérarchie ça paraît dans
les sondages aujourd'hui très clairement
lorsqu'on connaît des incidents on n'en
parle pas ou on n'a pas à ses collègues
c'est d'eux dont on attend un soutien de
proximité peu aux chefs d'établissement
parce que on le soupçonne d'être dans
l'idéologie du pad vagues ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui même le pas de
vagues isme et qui est bien répandue
dans cette catégorie de responsables
j'ai eu un entretien récemment avec un
responsable du principal syndicat des
chefs d'établissement qui m'a déclaré
benoîtement au le pas de vagues 10 - oui
m'enfin faut pas exagérer on va quand
même pas jeter d'huile sur le feu
à propos des incidents dus à l'islamisme
donc on a encore cette idéologie puis
chez les responsables
institutionnels aussi le sentiment qu'il
faut apaiser les conflits que face à des
interlocuteurs qui peuvent apparaître
déterminé faut chercher des compromis et
que dont les principes de la république
peuvent au fond se négocier on peut en
discuter
et si d'aménager des accommodements
raisonnables
voilà donc je pense avoir terminé mon
exposé et pour vous montrer le faire un
panorama de ce de la manière dont
l'islamisme a pénétré l'école et de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui qu'il ne serait peut-être
pas celle là si on avait traité le
courage de traiter cette question plutôt
mais enfin aujourd'hui il ya un projet
de loi justement sur cette question je
ne parle pas que de l'école mais je suis
à votre disposition pour engager un
dialogue et séchées de répondre mieux
possible à vos questions merci mesdames
et messieurs merci le constat est posée
jeune dauphin l'attenté de des questions
qui vont naître de cette présentation en
commençant par les deux rapporteurs
stephen pieds-noirs et ensuite dominique
derrien merci c'est le président
remercie de vos propos de votre
présentation
évidemment qui a attiré notre attention
dans le prolongement de deux des
productions vous avez pu faire par le
passé
tout le monde est là l'on pense au
rapport de 2004 mais également aux
livres très très fourni très détaillée
que vous avez écrit il ya été publié une
petite année maintenant si si je résume
un petit peu votre pont fait et vous
écris aussi d'ailleurs vous avez quand
même un regard très critique sur
l'action et sur la volonté du président
macron de lutter fille l'effectif mans
contre le séparatisme
[Musique]
c'est pas anodin mais vous citez
henri queuille en introduction de votre
livre il n'y a aucun problème politique
une absence de décision ne saurait
résoudre ça traduit d'après vous je
pense la ligne politique
emmanuel macron vous avez émis aussi des
doutes sur l'utilité de l'outil de
signalements mis en place par jean
michel blanquer en 2018 pour permettre
aux enseignants de signaler les
manquements à la laïcité principe de
laïcité dans les établissements dit que
cet outil est imparfait forcément et
surtout on a très brièvement
ça rejoint cette autocensure que vous
évoquiez dans l'instant dans vos propos
donc que faut-il faire concrètement pour
que ces manquements à la laïcité soit
plus visible pour être sanctionné
évidemment c'est que vous êtes également
chargé par le même ministre blanc caire
d'une mission pour justement travailler
sur la formation des enseignants à ce
principe de la laïcité
vous nous direz sans doute peut-être
l'avancée de vos travaux est en tout cas
ce que vous pensez de l'article 1 bis
qui prévoit justement un renforcement de
la formation dans les faits de formation
des futurs enseignants sur 7 sur cette
pratique laïcité mais par rapport à 2004
évidemment beaucoup d'autres phénomènes
on court je veux je veux parler de la
perception de la laïcité par les jeunes
eux-mêmes à l'intérieur des
établissements vous fait un distinguo
très nette entre le signifiant et le
signifié la loi de 2004
s'intéresse se portaient précisément
plus sur le signifier c'est à dire la
manifestation d'un attachement à une
religion plutôt que signifiant qu'ils
aient le qui est le voile par exemple où
la barde donc cette perception est en
train de glisser parmi les jeunes est
aussi parmi les enseignants et ça c'est
plus grave on en parle peu mais il ya
l'effet des manifestations de
séparatisme
parmi les enseignants eux mêmes est-ce
qu'il vous semble opportun par exemple
d'étendre la signature d'un serment
républicains à l'ensemble des
enseignants lors de l'obtention de leur
couple troisième question concernant les
certificats de ps certificats de
complaisance pour vous venez dire qu'ils
sont c'est une pratique massive
je dois dire que on a un écart un grand
écart avec ce que nous disent là dessus
les syndicats enseignants de ps on est à
l'opposé total opposé donc pas de mettre
de jugement de valeur sur les armes sur
les autres enfin si on nous signale un
mouvement massif sur les certificats de
complaisance et sans doute qu'on a des
éléments prouvant là dessus faut-il
alourdir ses pénalement répréhensible
faut-il alourdir les sanctions envers
les médecins qui établissent des
certificats de complaisance
doit-on davantage faire remonter les
informations auprès des médecins
scolaires dont on sait qu'ils sont en
nombre insuffisant en france voilà aussi
les questions sur le ps et puis pour
finir vous avez évoqué l'université en
2004 on a sans douté et dans les années
qui ont suivi on a sans doute manqué une
étape l'étape suivante d'aller voir un
petit peu à l'université ce qui se passe
et là encore nous avons des versions
très différentes des descriptions dit
très différente selon qu'on s'adresse à
un enseignant qui est au coeur de deux
sont en fille et de son université et
puis des parfois des présidents
d'université glisse que ça se règle dans
le dialogue
considérez vous qu'il faut là aussi
établir un marqueur de la laïcité
à l'intérieur pas forcément à
l'intérieur de l'anc
dans des campus c'est la problématique
est évidemment différente par rapport à
celle des collèges et des lycées mais
sur l'étang de cours nous avons des
fonctionnaires qui exercent dans des
lieux dédiés à l'enseignement
faut-il imposer une forme de neutralité
en tout cas pour les pour les étudiants
eux mêmes
journal bien c'est à moi parce que je
tombe micro doit être débranchées mais
pas
j'ai trouvé vous tenter coûte dominique
babin merci beaucoup merci monsieur
aubin de de ce constat qu effectivement
on a essayé de se voiler souvent si le
terme est peut-être mal choisi mais du
coup je vais continuer par rapport aux
sorties scolaires puisque on est par une
diversité est ce que vous pensez que
comme la loi de 2004 ce sera un
apaisement
ou plutôt vu l'état actuel un
embrasement
si jamais on arrive à obtenir une
neutralité
considérant que les bénévoles du service
public lors l'occurrence de l'éducation
nationale quand elles sont dans le
bâtiment quand ils sont dans le bâtiment
doivent avoir une neutralité politique
et religieuse
et puis lors des sorties scolaires ne
serait plus obligé de le faire par
ailleurs est ce que vous pensez pas que
le combat va être compliqué parce que je
crains que en fait la télé américaine et
gagner nos esprits et donc cette notion
très anglo-saxonne qui veille à m à
respecter toute religion et qui n'a pas
du tout cette notion de laïcité va
peut-être être semble avoir un peu gagné
les esprits et peut-être qu'il est
difficile de lutter et du coup à ma
question c'est comment est ce qu'on peut
faire pour ramener cette notion de
laïcité dans le coeur de
notre éducation de telle sorte qu
effectivement tout son sens en part et
qu'on la considère plus comme un bis
bien fait une source d'émancipation
plutôt que comme une contrainte comme
c'est aujourd'hui considérés merci
on va essayer de répondre à l'ensemble
je vais essayer de répondre à l'ensemble
de vos questionnements
alors concernant le président de la
république
mon sentiment enfin c'est pas je ne
pense pas je n'ai jamais dit que il
était dans une conception dans la lignée
de recueil le en même temps la
philosophie dur en même temps c'est pas
tout à fait la même mais mais je pense
que très sincèrement le priant de la
république a évolué sur cette question
il y défend aujourd'hui les conceptions
qui ne sont pas tout à fait seul qui
était seul avec lesquels il était arrivé
au pouvoir bien sans doute prise de
conscience d'un certain nombre de
réalités
en tout cas jean michel blanquer à lui
est très déterminé sur la laïcité et sur
sa volonté de d'imposer cette laïcité et
de la faire vivre avec les difficultés
que j'ai que j'ai évoqués sur l'outil
qu'il a mis au point deux signalements
on a aujourd'hui des études qui montrent
pourquoi c'est à dire que dans
l'éducation nationale
plus plus la hiérarchie est élevé moins
lui fait confiance et qu'on fera
davantage confiance à la hiérarchie de
proximité son inspecteur son chef
d'établissement qu'à celle du rectorat
et donc on voit cette réalité dans les
chiffres des dernières études
donc on cède maintenant très précisément
pourquoi les signalements sont la partie
émergée de l'iceberg des incidents est
donc dans des proportions qui peuvent
être considérables est ce pour autant
qu'on doit se se désinvestir de cet
outil ou l'abandonner je ne pense pas
c'est à dire que les référents laïcité
et leurs équipes dans les académies
traite effectivement un certain nombre
de signalements qui sont sans doute
parmi les plus graves
il n'entraîne pas beaucoup par rapport à
la masse des incidents mais il faut
quand même un certain travail et on
aurait tort d'abandonner cet outil mais
il faut les le manier avec précaution
c'est à dire que les chiffres qui
remontent au ministère n'ont pas
beaucoup de signification
voilà et l'inspection générale dans son
rapport de novembre 2019 les dit
ouvertement ces chiffres de ce que
peuvent en aucun cas qu'on s'y être
considérés comme des statistiques et les
ex otages nous donne des chiffres ont
bien plus intéressant vous donc de ce
point de vue continuer sans doute le
traité les signalements
mais la grande affaire n'est pas
simplement de les traiter ses dires il
ya tous ceux qui passent sous les ordres
du radar est là bien il faut outiller à
mon avis les enseignants les former de
manière préventive et est de manière
générale et on se heurte à beaucoup de
difficultés
bon j'ai commencé effectivement j'ai
maintenant à peu près vu l'ensemble des
acteurs et je vais m'atteler là dans les
jours qui viennent à commencer la partie
de la rédaction de la partie bilan est à
des lieues de mon rapport
bon il ya une une partie du système
éducatif qui est absolument sinistrés
par rapport au traitement de la laïcité
c'est le premier degré puisque là le
nombre de formation à la laïcité a chuté
depuis trois ans de manière considérable
pour être maintenant totalement
confidentielle cette année enfin l'or
l'an dernier plus tôt avant le
confinement la dernière année où on peut
avoir des chiffres ont peu intéressant
et fiable
c'est moins d'un instituteur sur 100 qui
a reçu dans l'année une formation d'une
journée à l'aller cité moins de 1 sur
100 on peut dire la formation est
obligatoire il faut tous les enseignants
soient formés mons heurte là des
difficultés sont budgétaire d'une fois
manque de moyens de remplacement qui
sont des difficultés stratégique
on a tout mis en terme de formation sur
les mathématiques et le français
au vu des résultats de pisa est rien
pour le reste bon et on est passé de 2
30 mille journées stagiaires à trois
mille journées stagiaires en trois ans
voilà diminué par dix donc on n'a
peut-être pas accorder une priorité
suffisante à ceux à cette question
j'ajoute après une visite dans un
certain nombre d'écoles primaires que la
conception de la laïcité qui est
développée est très très flou bon le
respect de l'autre le respect de l'autre
la laïcité c'est le respect de l'autre
des choses assez étonnante alors
l'article 1 bis du coup sur la formation
on va déjà avoir un mouvement de grève
la dent les insp et sur les
la réforme des concours et la réforme
des maquettes et en particulier une
opposition sur la question de la laïcité
bon il y a dans les insp et comme dans
l'enseignement supérieur en général des
courants de pensée qui traite la laïcité
comme quelque chose qui est je cite un
discours qui stigmatise les musulmans et
donc des recherches se développe
aujourd'hui y compris dans les insp et
sur les discours que que masquer la
laïcité qui sont des discours
islamophobe
à tel point que d'enjeux un institut on
m'a signalé hier que ces laboratoires de
recherche dont petits font des
publications et qui évidemment dirige
les mastères aujourd'hui une partie de
ces master key qui conduisent vers
l'enseignement engagé les étudiants
futurs enseignants dans des mémoires qui
consistait à les observer dans les
classes
le discours islamophobe des enseignants
avec la préconisation aux dix étudiants
ne dites surtout pas aux professeurs sur
quoi ce que vous venez observer dans sa
classe donc voila moi les bras m'en
tombent que je vois des choses comme ça
que pour dire que le mal est profond
dans certaines dans certaines dans
certaines universités et y compris dans
la formation des enseignants
donc imposé aux insp et de former à la
laïcité est une bonne chose
encore faut-il savoir à qui on confie
cette formation laquelle formateur on
les confie 6 et de déconstruire la
laïcité puisque c'est ça leur projet ben
je préfère encore qu'on fasse pas de
formation à la laïcité personnellement
donc voilà attention les meilleures
intentions du monde
il ne suffit pas de d'imposer aux
aspects de faire une formation saleh
cité il faut être capable de contrôler
vraiment ce qui s'y fait et ça c'est une
autre paire de manches de plus si je
puis me permettre
les in space et la formation initiale il
reste l'absence de formation le manque
de formation considérable de la masse
des enseignants en place aujourd'hui 6 %
des enseignants
enfin en 2018 plutôt 6% des enseignants
poste déclarait avoir reçu une formation
à la laïcité 6%
donc le besoin je dis pas les attentes
mais les besoins de formation sont
énormes
ne faudrait-il pas mettre dans la loi
quelque chose qui impose à l'éducation
nationale de former rapidement la masse
des enseignants en poste et la
l'employeur éducation nationale a
davantage de maîtrise de l'outil de
formation pour contrôler la nature de
ces formations avec les insp et qui sont
des instituts à cheval entre le
supérieur et et le l'éducation nationale
la maîtrise de l'outil est beaucoup plus
aléatoire moi j'ai enseigné jusqu'en
elin spe de versailles je peux vous dire
que bon la direction ne contrôle rien
que le responsable du master ne contrôle
pas grand chose et que c'est le
professeur qui enseigne la laïcité qui
sans aucun contrôle va imposer sa
conception de la laïcité comme sur
d'autres sujets d'ailleurs dès qu'on
rentre dans le domaine d
de la vie scolaire et qu'on n'est pas
dans le domaine évidemment disciplinaire
des mathématiques du français au là on a
une corpus de connaissances qui fait
consensus dans une communauté
là sur tous les sujets ce n'est pas le
cas et chacun est libre et sans contrôle
de faire à peu près ce qu'il veut donc
il ya une vraie difficulté sur la
question du voile
faut-il j'ai bien compris votre question
légiférer sur la question du voile dans
l'enseignement supérieur
personnellement j'y suis pas favorable
parce que je vous rappelle pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
je vous appelle la raison pour
lesquelles on a légiféré en 2004 sur
cette question à l'initiative de la
commission stasi dont les membres
étaient opposés à une loi au départ et
ce qui les a fait basculer c'est ce sont
les auditions les auditions d'élèves les
auditions de chefs d'établissement qui
leur ont décrit la pression sociale qui
s'exerçait dans les établissements sur
ces lycéennes ou ces collégiennes pour
qu'elles se conforment à cette à ce
vêtement est à ce signe religieux
ce que nous avons observé c'est que
certes sans trop de problème les voiles
avait disparu à la rentrée 2004 mais que
les atteintes à la laïcité bon dans tous
les domaines bon on était et est
manifeste et n'ont fait que se
développer
donc je dirais ne ne recommençons pas
peut-être de nous focaliser sur un signe
alors que les atteintes à la laïcité et
ceux qui se développent aujourd'hui dans
l'enseignement supérieur d'une bien
et et de bien plus grande gravité que ce
signe religieux qui de plus s'adressant
à des adultes on peut réfléchir à la
question de la pression sociale et de la
liberté de conscience alors sur sur le
séparatisme parmi les enseignants oui
aujourd'hui d'après les chiffres du
ministère mais il faut les prendre je
voulais lit avec des pincettes
11% des auteurs des incidents sont des
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
j'ai eu plusieurs écoles à dents mais
dans mes investigations très récente
pour ma vision de d'enseignants ou le
groupe d'enseignants d'origine musulmane
qui ouvertement professait presque
ouvertement professait des conceptions
l'hostis laïcité et même on m'a parlé
d'une association qui leur groupe est
aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient voilà un site
internet
donc ceci existe évidemment très
inquiétant en général ces incidents à la
cantine par exemple mais aussi dans la
classe provoquées par des personnels
voire des enseignants vise les lycéens
et les collégiens musulmans pour les
rappeler alors à la religion plutôt un
certain nombre de signes qui le doivent
manifester à la cantine par exemple
incidents fréquents
une dame de service c'est-à-dire
personnel fonctionnaire territorial dit
à un élève tu mange du porc toi mais ta
religion tu interdite voilà une
intervention comme ça une
accompagnatrice colère qui dit à aux
élèves
bon il faut porter le voile vous élève
musulman musulmane en l'occurrence voilà
des interventions de ce type qui sont
évidemment des des entorses au principe
de laïcité voilà j'ai eu quelques
témoignages en ce cas est-ce qu'un
serment pourrait changer cela voilà
toute la question est dans la sincérité
du serment lorsqu'on va le passer je
pense que l'enjeu de rentrer dans la
fonction publique peut faire abandonner
tout on dirait toute sincérité
d'autant plus qu'on connaît la pratique
de la taqiyya qui est la dissimulation
qui est pratiqué par les islamistes donc
je doute de l'efficacité de ce serment
on cherche à introduire en ce moment on
travaille sur une épreuve de l'ensemble
des concours qui l'épreuve numéro 2 de
l'admission c'est-à-dire de l'oral dont
une partie consiste à être interrogé sur
le principe de laïcité et la manière de
gérer les incidents dans la classe donc
on espère beaucoup enfin le ministère
le ministre espère beaucoup de cette de
cette de la capacité de trier
bon la conception entre les candidats
ceux qui ont une véritable sincérité
dans la compte dans leur conception de
la laïcité et ceux qui resteraient à
catéchisme mais nous en sommes à la
définition de cette épreuve et je
voulais vous dans les insp et c'était
preuve recueillie forte hostilité de la
part des formateurs elle a été vilipendé
avant même d'être connu on va leur faire
réciter un catéchisme
c'est du formatage idéologique et voilà
ce qu'ont ce qu'on lit dans les
publications de certains professeurs
d'xp ou sur les sites concernant le ps
et le certificat de les certificats de
complaisance et c'est vrai que
personnellement j'ai recueilli beaucoup
de témoignages de chefs d'établissement
sur 7 sur ses certificats de
complaisance et par diverses cap divers
canaux
j'ai entendu que il y avait une
une mission qui avait été confiée
je suis plus à qui d'ailleurs sur ses
certificats d'allergie au chlore pour la
piscine qui est une partie seulement des
certificats de complaisance mais qui
j'ai pu l'observer dans un lycée il y a
deux trois ans peut concerner une
majorité d'élèves musulmane qui refusent
d'aller à la piscine et qui s'abrite
derrière ces certificats de complaisance
attendons le résultat de cette mission
pour voir quelle est la réalité des
fêtes dans les sondages je voulais dit
l'éducation physique et sportive le ps
est la discipline la plus concernée
aujourd'hui d'après les professeurs par
ces manquements à la laïcité ces
incidents que les syndicats si j'ai bien
compris dénis cette réalité ça ne
m'étonne pas vu ces syndicats que je
connais bien qui sont affiliés à la fsu
d'un syndicat qui est plutôt profération
qui est plutôt dans la négation le déni
ou l'atténuation de ce fait de même en
tout cas qui ne veut pas les en faire
une question qui doit être traité comme
tel
en fait il ya des divisions à
l'intérieur de chèques
de cette fédération mais la majorité
aujourd'hui majorité traditionnellement
d'extrême gauche qui si qui est dans la
complaisance par rapport à ces
idéologies
voilà vous posez la question aussi des
présidents d'université je les connais
peu mais d'après ce que j'entends dire
c'est pire que les chefs
d'établissements du secondaire
c'est-à-dire le déni et généraliser le
pad vague isme règne en maître
voilà on va régler ça par la discussion
tout ça n'est pas grave enfin on exagère
beaucoup les phénomènes les problèmes
bon je pense franchement que aujourd'hui
concernant l'enseignement supérieur le
problème majeur n'est pas l'islamisme
c'est un certain nombre d' idéologie
venue des états unis et pas de l'islam
qui pervertissent complètement la
recherche française et qui impose une
doxa à l'ensemble des deux départements
de sciences humaines qui fait qu' il n'y
a plus de variété des recherches il n'y
a plus de réellement de liberté
académique
c'est à dire que ceux qui crient le plus
fort à la volonté de l'état d'imposer
afin de contrarier ou de ligoter les
libertés académiques sont de fait dans
ces départements ce qui empêche la
liberté académique et on a des preuves
de plus en plus fréquentes
[Musique]
bon la réponse de la conférence des
présidents d'université immédiate à la
sortie de la ministre frédéric vidal sur
l'islamo gauchisme tri mais qui est sans
doute pas le terme le plus approprié
pour désigner ce qui se passe montre
quand même que l'aïe
il ya un déni de la réalité qui ne peut
pas être total c'est pas possible mais
qui en fait dissimule une cour dise
certaines l'accession des
accompagnateurs scolaires des
accompagnatrices colère c'est à dire ces
femmes voilées qui accompagnent les
sorties scolaires
alors aujourd'hui sur le plan du droit
il est vrai que le conseil d'état ou
plutôt l'ensemble de la justice
administrative à deux jurisprudences
développe de jurisprudence une pour les
personnes qui interviennent dans les
classes des parents ou autres
intervenants extérieurs pour lesquelles
en exigent les mêmes obligations
imposées même obligation pour les agents
publics c'est à dire de ne pas avoir de
signes ostentatoires et puis les
accompagnateurs scolaire qui eux
le conseil d'état a décidé ainsi
récemment sont considérés comme des
parents et donc et non comme des
encadrants
auxiliaire de l'enseignant et ont la
possibilité de manifester leur religion
mais il ya une limite à cette
manifestation qui est l'absence de
prosélytisme on a un article du code de
l'éducation qui interdit le prosélytisme
comment une sortie scolaire
donc la difficulté est la suivante on
est dans le premier degré dans la quasi
totalité des cas le directeur d'école
qui n'a pas d'autorité sur les
enseignants qui est un instituteur
encore si ça décolle comme les autres
chargé d'une mission jeunes une fonction
à la responsabilité la charge de
regarder si pendant les sorties
scolaires
il y a eu une phrase élitisme ou pas
et dans le cas où il pense qu'il eût
prosélytisme cas d'un certain nombre de
situations et bien d'empêcher ces mères
de participer de nouveau
et alors là qu'est ce qui se passe on a
voilà il ya plus et seief mais enfin on
va avoir d'autres recours juridique
on va le directeur est traîné devant
tribunal administratif et une pression
et en particulier dans certains
quartiers qui est insupportable pour les
directeurs ne peuvent pas assumer cette
responsabilité
voilà il faut il faut le il faut le
savoir
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
e
dernière dernière question que vous
m'avez posé madame c'est à propos de la
conception américaine qui qui est
dominante aujourd'hui chez nos lits
siens comme le montre le dernier sondage
moi même j'ai rencontré la semaine
dernière une deux une quelques dizaines
de lycéens dans un grand lycée
international à fontainebleau
pas n'importe quel lycéen ce qui ferait
pas sciences po ou qui font option
grands enjeux du monde contemporain en
terminale es en première donc des jeunes
qui sont vraiment le fort mais sur le
plan politique que d'autres sans doute
plus sensibles à ces questions et j'ai
vu effectivement à travers les questions
qui m'étaient posées de jeunes très
respectueux par ailleurs on va poser la
question de la conception de la laïcité
américaines comme s'il y avait une
conception de la laïcité américaine qui
était plus accommodante et qui avaient
visiblement leur faveur parce que au
fond vous
les jeunes filles ont le droit de porter
le voile et tout se passe très bien
donc pourquoi compliquer les choses
[Musique]